i wanted to bring this up there's we had
talked about this in the past but this
is a uh story about miss excel
so her name she calls herself miss excel
and i don't know if you've ever seen her
i don't think you're a big tick tock guy
but i am i had seen this person going
viral on tick tock and basically it's a
woman who
puts out like
microsoft excel
tips and tricks like little hacks like
oh
you know how your um
things are always like poorly formatted
just put pushed like you know command g
when you're hovering over the column and
look it auto formats everything
perfectly or like do you know what a
vlookup is you do this this and this and
boom you can find anything so she
basically puts out these little clips on
tick tock but it's not just the content
like the way she does it it's like
what works on tick tock it's like
cute cute girls dancing humor like these
are the things that like work on tick
tock
and so she does that she's like she'll
put a song like that's like a trending
song on tick tock
um she'll dress up she'll be she'll have
the screen screen share behind her and
she's kind of overlaid on top of it and
then she's showing something funny
that's like something that's happening
she's explaining it quickly and in an
entertaining way so
she's uh she's here's her story she's a
consultant um
kind of a boring job she was a
consultant
and she decided you know there's a lot
of consultants and bankers that if you
watch the music sell they won't touch a
mouse
like they just used a keyboard like a
wizard and like they could just do
everything just by hitting like
shortcuts and macros on their on the
keyboard in excel there's actually a lot
of people that could do this
who who used to work at bcg basically
they had a mouse with like a wired mouse
that was clearly cut the cord was cut
and they like it was like in a frame on
the wall and they're like that's what
you're gonna do here the mouse that's
what this needs to look like you don't
use the mouse exactly uh and i don't
know how any of this works but uh i've
definitely seen a bunch of friends who
can do this they it's kind of amazing
when they're doing it so
she basically took that idea and started
turning into interesting clips so she
starts off and she tells the story where
she's like you know um
i wanted to like try making some content
and uh you know tick-tock i felt
embarrassed because like isn't tick-tock
like for kids and like it's just like
the silly thing to do i shouldn't i
shouldn't make a take out account i'm a
consultant and then her gut was like you
should do a tick-tock and so she listens
to her gut she makes a tick-tock and
pretty quickly i think within the first
week or so she goes viral with one or
two clips and she gets over like a
hundred thousand views and she's like
holy this is awesome
and so she does it again and she does it
again and then she starts to she's like
buys a little ring light and gets a
green screen so that it looks a little
bit better and she does it again she
gets a video that gets a million views
and it's like wow this is amazing and so
she starts branding herself amazing
branding by the way miss excel like she
is the one she is the excel woman and um
and so i thought that was great and so
she starts doing this and she's getting
popular but she's not making any money
and uh she reaches or who what happened
morning brew reaches out they're gonna
do a feature story on her and they're
like oh we want to feature you and at
the same time a business coach reached
out to her and was like hey i saw you
have this like really great following i
think your your content is super unique
um
you know and she was like yeah it's
great i'm gonna be featured on morning
brew they're like awesome like what do
you have to sell she's like i don't sell
anything it's all free content and
they're like if you're gonna get
featured you should have something to
sell and she's like okay challenge
accepted you're right
i'm gonna make a course and so she
decides to make a course
she's never done it before and i think
she had like something like two weeks or
something to like pull this whole thing
off and she rushes to do it now let's
fast forward to today
she
is making courses and she is making um
six figures a month off this thing so
she's making single-digit millions a
year she has a few days
of the year where she's made six feet
over a hundred thousand dollars on a day
in course sales that's kind of like her
black friday um or black friday special
or whatever where she where she sold her
course and so she's doing millions of
dollars a year and she's working towards
million a million dollar month that's
like her goal i want to hit a million
dollars a month as miss excel
and she is like microsoft loves her
they're like pumping her up um you know
she's featured in business insider she's
featured in like buzzfeed she's featured
in a whole bunch of places because this
great story she's featured on this
podcast right now and so she is doing
amazing what i love about this is she
quits her job as a consultant she now
works 15 hours a week unless she's
making a course like but just like a
normal thing she's she's doing 50 hours
a week
she has one employee which is an
overseas virtual assistant her cost
structure is that overseas virtual
assistant which i'm guessing is making
something like six to ten dollars an
hour so you know probably paying them
like five hundred dollars a month
ballpark
plus uh she pays 97 dollars for
thinkific which is the course platform
and she pays a video editor to um to
edit the videos for the course so like
all in all her expenses are probably
like sub fifteen hundred dollars maybe
some two thousand dollars at the time
and um she's making six figures a month
so she's profiting
um you know at least a hundred thousand
dollars a month uh doing this thing and
um there was a whole bunch of like
different little nuggets in there that i
liked but that's the the overall story
quick quick reaction to that
amazing i don't think it's gonna
maybe it will last
maybe that was that was my initial
instinct i was like
awesome run but like you know who knows
if this is here two years from now
and then i changed my mind when i kind
of read her read a little bit more about
her here's what i liked okay so we had
talked about excel
way back maybe a year ago when i when we
were talking about i was going to create
a course and we had done a deep dive of
what are the best courses it's always
excel microsoft excel is always on the
top if you go to teachables top courses
udemy's top courses
learning to master excel is always in
the top like 10 earning courses and you
think it's hard to be the one but it's a
topic people will pay for anker from
teachable he's got a he's a good twitter
follow he uh tweets out some of the
biggest earners he won't explicitly say
who they are but he'll say one earner we
just paid their
you know they just crossed 20 million in
in revenue or in like earnings
and then he'll also say like the top
course is this excel thing so you can
kind of like triangulate
exactly and and on udemy i think i was
able to do this as well i was able to
search and sort for the top best-selling
courses and excel was in the top as well
that's amazing
and um so i think excel has real demand
then the question is who's gonna be
the best brand in the excel space
and
she's the horse i would pick so um why
do i think that first is her content is
fundamentally better she took the most
um she has the best top of funnel so
what's her top of funnel strategy it's
highly exciting quick hitting snack
sized tick tock videos tick tock itself
is like the crack cocaine of content
right like 10 seconds video
with music overlaid that is crack
cocaine for content and she's using that
for excel when all the other excel
creators are like bloggers and like
that there's like a stale old thing
then her brand and her personality miss
excel
good looking woman who understands how
to do content and um and she i know she
understands the content she says she's a
little bit when i was researching her
she
is really into some of the i'm into
that's really like kind of like off the
beaten path so she was like yeah she's
like most people when they think of
content strategy like especially for for
this space b2b type of content she's
like it's always like strategic
intellectual trying to figure it out she
goes i spend most of my time
just getting into a certain state of
mind i just she's like i just get into a
she she goes
this is her exact quote she goes the way
i run my structure for my business is
through energetics most people don't
even know what the that means
she goes i get my energy to a place
where my presence is truly magnetic i
get a vision of what's going to go viral
then i run to my computer and i create
that and sure enough it goes viral she
goes because most content people people
don't understand content is just energy
transmission yeah i'm having a great
time i'm excited about this topic and so
i'm gonna push that through the phone
into you and sure enough you're gonna
learn something but you're also gonna
smile while you're watching my
you're also gonna laugh while you're
watching my thing and nobody else is
doing that and i've read that and i go
she gets it she gets like one of the
most important things about business and
life which is it's like being able to
manage your own energy but the second
part is she gets the content strategy in
a way that i don't think anybody else is
gonna really get in this in this space
the second thing is
go ahead go ahead she now has scales so
at first i was like okay but she's just
like an individual creator on tiktok and
like who knows maybe take talk algorithm
changes no so here's what she's doing
she basically is like i'm gonna scale in
two ways first she's expanding into the
whole microsoft suite so it's not just
excel she's doing powerpoint and word
and outlook and like
everything that like you know a billion
people on earth have to use
professionally and so and microsoft is
helping her and every time they're
releasing a new thing she's getting
first look at it and she gets to come
out right away with the content that's
going to highlight this new function or
this new feature that you get to be able
to use
so
that expansion gives it more legs than
just excel the second thing is she now
hired a performance marketing agency and
she's like yeah get my brand to grow and
she's like the beautiful thing is i
don't sell my course i just put my most
viral thing and i put ad spend behind it
and people love it like they love that
content and so they like it they comment
on it so facebook's algorithm promotes
it and so i was like oh that's kind of
an unstoppable like flywheel she's going
to keep creating this like juicy
like quick life hack type content
then she's promoting it uh that's
already inherently viral then she's
putting a paid ad spent behind it she's
growing her following on instagram now
plus tic toc plus youtube plus all these
different places um and she's like oh
yeah reels came out so then i just like
jumped on reels and i became like one of
the most viral reels creators on
instagram
and um so i'm like okay now she's
diversifying the audience and she's got
the courses behind it and she's going
into more more parts of the suite i like
that formula i was wrong she's gonna
she's gonna crush it i think she's gonna
get to my bold prediction
she's gonna get to a hundred million
dollars in sales and that sounds
outrageous i would like to say 100
million i think she could i think you
could do i think 100 million a year or
lifetime a year
uh yeah i actually agree with you i
think that's bold i think likely she'll
get to like 25 million dollars a year in
revenue and could probably actually do
that for
many years right
uh yeah i think it's crazy um so i loved
i loved her thing there was also these
other little nuggets so she basically
she's working 15 hours a week so then
she's like oh cool quit my job i'm going
to be a digital nomad something you kind
of did this last year she's like every
month me and my boyfriend we just moved
to a different state we just want to
experience it so they'll just move to a
different state in america and just like
hang out there for the month and they
hop around and uh
the other thing that she's the other
nuggets i liked was she does these like
webinars because she understands there's
like a top of funnel
so top of funnel if you don't know is
basically like how you get new customers
to even like get in touch with you get
in get into your cases it's just going
viral on tick tock going viral on tick
tock or instagram or youtube great then
she has the middle of funnel which is
where a lot of people fall out which is
okay you've touched base with me once
you're not ready to buy something just
yet but how do i actually get you to
participate in a deeper way to invest in
a deeper way and for her she runs these
webinars and she calls them high energy
excel parties and so she she invites
people to these and what happens is it's
of course it's like someone from bcg and
then they go and they're like oh this is
amazing then they're like hey we'd like
to buy like 1500 seats for our for your
course for our company you know like or
hey i work for target uh corporate
training and uh yeah we have 25 000
employees that we think would be benefit
from this how do could you create
something custom for us and it's gonna
be like yeah here's the same thing but
now i say the word target at the
beginning and i charge you you know five
million dollars for